hello
[Music]
I'm imagining that you're Iranian yes I
am well spotted
first ever anything I've done where
you've got my name right on the first
try okay I'm sure trust me I've been
there yeah
relatable
okay so you hurt my feelings the movie
you did not obviously hurt my feelings
um what spoke to you
what about it spoke to you at the
project Nicole Hall of Center
and Julia Louis-Dreyfus were the two
main engines
um I've I've seen Nicole's work uh since
the 90s vlogging and talking
piece throughout and
um
and I I grew up with Julie Louis drivers
I I grew up with that Geo Seinfeld and I
I wanted to I wanted to understand how
they made all the jokes I wanted to
understand you know I was obsessed with
it
that was the first thing
Nicole's work you're going to get
something very honest
she's looking for like really honest
simple
tragic hilarious
um people
so that's that's those are the reasons
right
like like touching on that it's very
honest very tragic the Arts in general
can sometimes be so thankless as a
profession and I think that's something
that the movie touches on really well
with like Mark and obviously with Beth
so what do you think in those moments is
the key to like staying motivated God
that is a great question
you just you know
you just need little pieces of
validation along the way to like so
sometimes like a good audition could be
like three weeks of positivity
mine yeah
um but sometimes you get only an
audition once you know every six months
so then all of a sudden you're putting a
lot of eggs in that validation basket
which might not kind of come through so
um I think one way of doing it is just
trying to get more at bats I guess to
try to get out there more so you know
you can take the hits more it's a tough
thing you know I have so many you know I
teach and I teach high school students
and have so many actors that quit at 23
24 25 and I get it because it's too hard
or they don't really love it and and so
it's it's a hard thing to kind of just
know what you are supposed to do you
know it's it's tough and so
um I can imagine a lot of people like
getting real down real quick so
obviously you are a successful actor but
did you ever hit that point like Mark
did where you're just like there is like
is this path worth it what's the point
I'm sure you must have maybe I mean that
we yeah totally I'm you know I've been
doing this for 21 years yeah and then
you most people only just see me for six
of those 21 years yeah no yeah oh
totally I still have those feelings
sometimes if I'm being honest with you I
mean the feeling doesn't go away
um it's too real
right you can do one I know friends of
mine that are geniuses Emmy winners
Oscar winners that do one play do get
one bad review and wants to run away
that's so real it's it's it's so hard
it's so
um
it's a tricky Beast trying to be an
artist in this world you know and I
think that's something the movie like
throughout the whole thing just captured
so so well so well
yeah yeah exactly
so pivoting just a second for succession
one of the projects people recently know
you for um and the slightly terrifying
Stewie hussaini um were there any kind
of off-screen elements that informed how
you played him like did you make a
backstory beyond what we already know or
no you know
well we kind of it was all just kind of
shared I mean that by Jesse and I had a
conversation about
where like when he about him being
Iranian and when he came over and all
that but after we had that conversation
I was very honest I was like
whatever we decide here it doesn't have
to be talked about in the show I think
part of the what I was really hoping for
is that we can leave him being Stewie
husseini and people just accept him for
what he is that happens to be Iranian
and at that level I think that you know
it's not defined he's not defining him
that was very important to me
um
um yeah and and and you know it's the
relationships of you know I've known
Jeremy since you know I've known German
since I was he was 19 or I was 19 and he
was 20 or something and you know it's a
lot a lot of these Afters are in the
theater communities I've seen them
around and we've hung out at things and
so you know a lot of that backstory is
just feeling safe in this like
environment like act in the best way
that you can and that was done pretty
quickly because of um
you know just just yeah how we all kind
of like knew each other you kind of had
that Bond it's just like in a different
context now yeah exactly exactly exactly
as an actor if you're jumping between
genres of something super grounded like
you hurt my feelings and then upcoming
House of spoils which is like more on
the horror side is that something that
you feel when you're performing or is
there like does it just kind of distill
down to the truth of your character and
the genre doesn't really come into it
you know you mentioned four things that
are like you know completely have
different mindsets but let's talk about
right you know um you hurt my feelings
you hurt my feelings Nicole has written
truthful characters
and they have to be really deeply
truthful we know that it's funny we
can't worry too much about all the jokes
all the time we have to worry about
making it so truthful
you know what I mean and so
um and so in that way and we have Nicole
so as a writer as she as the writer
director it's very easy for us to like
lean into her but for for something like
um
something like a house of spoils that
you just mentioned um
um we're also telling a psychological
Thriller horror do you know what I mean
like so we also know a genre we're in
so you're trying to be truthful but
you're also trying to live in the world
of this story you know I I was told this
um when I was doing inventing Anna
um
well like the Shonda team that like that
I act a little bit like a writer
because I'm really interested about the
truth but I'm also interested about
story
and what the story does to a thing so in
a doll's house right now you know
torvald is notoriously like a a real
kind of um hated character in the
theater and
um
and and
that's a tricky thing you know and at
the end of this story Nora has to you
know leave and we want the story to be
that this is some sort of moment of like
strength and power and and exuberance
you know and so in that scenario I as
the actor know that I have to be also
somehow defeated
right so I'm I'm thinking as a writer as
well as an actor and also trying to find
the truth so it just depends from
Project to project a long answer to your
very simple so you mentioned you're
thinking as an actor as a writer you are
also a director
um the accent on the Wolf season three
just came out are you eyeing another
chance to sit in the director's chair
maybe kind of once things calm down post
adult house I think there is where
there's a couple things in the works for
me being as a writer and director that
hopefully will the world will find out
about soon yeah I think I think that's a
big path of where I'm trying to move
towards so I wanna I wanna Circle back
to a doll's house for a second
um you've I'm going to tie these two
together you've been a very vocal
proponent of the ongoing Freedom
Movement in Iran something obviously
very close to my heart
um and I want to know because there's
not much people can do Beyond like
amplification what role do you think art
plays in keeping causes like this alive
it is the most essential
portion art is the most essential
portion for forward movement in society
the only two things that we have in
society
to look back on are Wars
are all the wars that we fought and all
the art that has survived
those are the two things that have
remained since the beginning of time the
art and the wars and so
um really I I have dedicated my life
with water well my nonprofit
um and and and with colleges like women
life freedom to say that art is an
essential tool for that forward momentum
it may be the most essential because if
you get people with a piece of art to
understand the quite and the the the the
and the hatred that women have under the
Islamic regime
and you get to people to empathize with
that and understand and put themselves
in that shoes in their in those shoes
you start to get to see a world that you
didn't know anything about
and start realizing well that is unjust
and art is a very easy mechanism for
people to do that because we are in the
game of empathy gimmick that's what this
that's what we do we are we're we're
going to empathize with our characters
in the theater and film and TV and your
job is to care about them in some sort
of way or not
um
and so and so I think it's very
essential and I think so much of the
movement uh and the revolution has been
happening because of the iPhone and
videos that people have been making you
know and and making little pieces of art
that's come out that out of that I think
you know the most important one being
the song which
um sharing hajipur was imprisoned for
um and just recently won a Grammy
um for this like social action song
that is the that is the new anthem of
the Iranian movement without any
question every Iranian knows every word
of that a piece of art did that
you know I I think it's essential and so
tying it back to kind of wrap it up with
you hurt my feelings
um for the creative types that go see it
what are you hoping that their takeaway
will be
like walking out of the theater I'm in
love with these two couples
I really am in love with these couples I
think they are navigating some tricky
Waters help with healthy
expectations they're doing it well and
what I hope people creatives take out of
it is
um is that it's funny I I went to the
positive what's your creative style that
was your question these are creative
um
I think we all have to get we all have
to get ready
and get we have to have thicker skin we
have to be able to take stuff you know
and and I think that might not happen in
any short lifetime but um but I think
because we're just also
imperfect people
um but I think it's one thing that we
can all learn Brothers just to like make
sure that
we can hear it from the ones closest to
us I guess I'm really speaking to myself
which which I guess is important you
want
right
also like even if she doesn't like it
she's just gonna give me a couple of
weeks of just like love just okay great
that's fine that's awesome uh I prefer
that I prefer that